hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast on
Monday July 4th 2016 how's it going
happy birthday to the United States of
America happy birthday to the United
States of America
happy birthday United States of America
in the North American cotton and happy
birthday to you what's going on and now
thank you for the well wishes of happy
birthday from all the other countries
around the world that realized we are
the best huh you think you got fat
people huh take a look at that beat that
[ __ ]
what else you think you can beat us in
huh well you want what do you want what
do you what kind of [ __ ] battle you
want you [ __ ] around the world you
stole our genes all those cool American
genes you guys would defect from your
country just to get over here to get a
pair of button-fly [ __ ] 5:01 blues
remember that [ __ ] all of a sudden you
know a couple of [ __ ] wars and
everybody forgets how much you love your
genes that's you know what that's just
typical that is just [ __ ] typical
you know [ __ ] English coming over
here D Landry [ __ ] cycling our
[ __ ] music walking around like
they're doing something redoing the
[ __ ] music from the people that we
didn't except [ __ ] you guys do it
anyways I'm having a great three-day
weekend I'm not doing [ __ ] I am uh I'm
back in the workout mode so the needle
is pointed in the right direction
old freckles was going dad [ __ ]
looked in the mirror last night I could
tell Oh start and lose weight made me
feel good you know to me it's a [ __ ]
tough thing being a redhead you know is
a really small window that you have to
exist in or else the beatings start
again and it's really something you
can't understand
alright I'm all over the [ __ ] place I
got a bunch of [ __ ] I have to do them
having some family over today for a
[ __ ] cookout I'm going easy this year
rather than trying to smoke something
and blah Leblon do all that [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] going burgers and dogs burgers
and dogs the way it used to be before
the [ __ ] Food Network showed up and
everybody's got to be like a Top Chef
you know remember you were growing up
that's what it was it was burgers and
dogs and everybody was [ __ ] happy
right till the boo started going around
then yeah I got a little sideways but it
happens so while yesterday I had some
friends over we had some cigars right
and you know the deal it's like are your
buddies are coming over your wife's
going to be like oh yeah
even if they're cool like my wife's cool
but there's always going to be an
element of hiding in up there they're
gonna be loud you gonna be upstairs and
I said it's like yeah I'm having people
over do I do that when you have a little
[ __ ] do I you have a moment for the
[ __ ] wind and you're all sitting
there laughing with your high-pitched
[ __ ] voices you don't think that
that's putting cracks in the walls I
don't I don't [ __ ] [ __ ] about it I
go down to the old [ __ ] hardware
store I get out to spackle alright and
with every little cattle right another
[ __ ] line in the wall you don't hear
me complaining got my putty knife out oh
you have a good time ladies right
anyways so we have we were hanging out
what's actually [ __ ] hilarious
because I've gone out and I bought you
know got some Cuban cigars I want to
[ __ ] it I cleaned everything up right
but thing what you want to do this is
what I've realized when you live in with
a woman what you want to do is you just
go all out right you [ __ ] I clean the
[ __ ] place up okay
I even like like the deck on the back
like I [ __ ] hosed it off so they
wouldn't be traits and dirt in and out
of the house or whatever right
she said they're going like wow really
going all out yeah there's a reason Sam
Kinison
there there's a [ __ ] reason why
because what you want to do is what
you're doing is you just put yourself
into a position where you did absolutely
nothing wrong so when they complain
because they're still going to complain
you got all of this [ __ ] ammo right I
clean this whole [ __ ] place up right
cleaned out the back porch down the back
yard the whole [ __ ] thing cleaned it
up and we having family over here today
which was another great one to be like
well I'm also doing it for your family
right so I'm doing all of this [ __ ] I
got I got the booze I got the [ __ ]
the outdoor patio furniture I got
everything all cleaned up
I got an ashtray upstairs I got one
downstairs I got the backyard lights on
I got the whole [ __ ] thing I got the
music I got the whole thing and then it
like six o'clock at night I realized I
didn't get cigars
I bought cigars but I don't have a
humidor and I said I was going to pick
them up and I had this [ __ ] panic
attack because it was Sunday before the
fourth that they were going to close and
it was six excruciating rings before
they picked up and I was able to run
down there and get him right and they
showed up I ordered some pizzas and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] and is the best part
right here is that car I my wife went to
sleep right which smoking with telling
[ __ ] stories you know I got all these
orange sodas for myself right and I
turns out everybody they wanted one
because it had the real [ __ ] and it went
great with the cigar I'm telling you
Cuban cigar and the Fanta orange soda is
the [ __ ] right they drank all my orange
soda so I did drink grape soda like a
[ __ ] six [ __ ] year old right so
anyways the end of the night you know
what I [ __ ] cleaned up everything you
wouldn't you wouldn't even [ __ ] know
you wouldn't know a goddamn you wouldn't
know that a [ __ ] soul was here and
that's what you do all these [ __ ]
married guys is today
that second worth it it is [ __ ] worth
it you just you just have to do it
perfectly right you go all out you clean
up the [ __ ] place they come over you
have a great [ __ ] time when you leave
you [ __ ] clean the whole place up
again what can she say what is she going
to say to you you're not allowed to have
friends little things like that because
I've had buddies am i coming over here
like on dude you [ __ ] what are you
doing you did all that and you [ __ ]
wash your dishes it's visit there's a
genius behind what I do I'm talking [ __ ]
here I'm drinking throw coke tea and I'm
talking [ __ ] what can they [ __ ] say
then what it is is if you do everything
perfectly then they're leaving
themselves totally exposed if they start
complaining that they're all that
basically can complain about at that
point is that you have friends and you
invited them over to the house all right
and they know they don't have a [ __ ]
leg to stand on
so the bitching goes down by like 90%
now if you have your [ __ ] friends
over and you leave the [ __ ] ashtray
out and there's footprints all over the
[ __ ] place they can make it about
that when the real thing is is they
don't want you to have friends right but
they can hide behind the other ship but
the real thing is they don't want you to
have friends and they want to slowly
kill you so that they can you know have
the house to themselves and if you you
know go to the obituaries there's a
bunch of guys dropping around 58 59 60
and that that's what happened what
really happened was they had friends
over and they didn't clean up you know
which gave their wives the window
- [ __ ] them into an early grave and now
they're sitting there in the [ __ ]
house having a hell of a time getting to
play the victim getting all the sympathy
cards and eating all the pound cake and
that the fact you know coming with the
truth here and fourth of July Hawking
talking about um anyways so afterwards
right so we're drinking sodas I'm stoned
so right and everybody leaves except for
one of my other buddies and he wasn't in
a eh
right the older you get the more your
friends just [ __ ] they quit you know
to me it just [ __ ] quick it's like
being a lifer in the military everybody
doesn't sign back up all of a sudden
you're the old guy
you know [ __ ] walking around where
that [ __ ] ball my friends go right
walking around all sad with you [ __ ]
Smokey the Bear hat I hate you so he
still drinks so they leave so I get out
the giant [ __ ] ice cubes and pour a
couple of Johnny blue right and you know
he has to drive so he's he's doing a
little sippy cup [ __ ] and I live here so
I'm doing the home force right thousand
one thousand two thousand three feet
right one of those pores so I have a
couple two three of those I'm feeling
good and you know but I'm not I clean
the whole [ __ ] tube when I cleaned
the whole all the leftover pizza I wrap
each slice individually in foil and then
I put a letter on it pay for pepperoni s
for sausage M for [ __ ] Margherita
took the pizza boxes out put them in the
recycle bin took out the [ __ ]
chemicals [ __ ] spray down the
counters you wouldn't [ __ ] to that
goddamn forensic team of forensic [ __ ]
with their [ __ ] dusters would coming
would have no [ __ ] idea anything
happened right so now I'm feeling all
proud of myself I got my little [ __ ]
sippy drink there and I put on the TV
because I'm not ready to go to bed yet
and what do I see time-life books or
whatever time life records presents
easy-listening love songs right and I'm
sitting there watching it right I'm not
don't [ __ ] it at me I'll see put your
picture on the wall cuz it stay there
right I'm like I remember that [ __ ]
song and we'll could forget this one
angle bird Humperdinck please
be let me go teetee ever listen to
lyrics of that song it's like for [ __ ]
sake just break up with her he only said
something like I'm talking about I found
a new love her lips are warm and yours
are so cold it's like Angle Park just
enough with the [ __ ] details just
break up with you just say look I'm not
in love with you anymore
you know gotta bring up the other
[ __ ] broad down the streets got your
heart racing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's such a country song but you know I
heard it when I was younger so I'm
listening to all of these [ __ ] songs
God doesn't make little green apples and
[ __ ] something-something battle and
next thing you know I'm on the phone
calling 1-800 give me those [ __ ] CDs
so the guy picks up the phone
he goes hey this is Rob from time life
records Who am I speaking to the seasons
like you're speaking of Bill Rob are you
doing buddy go I'll do it great look
what uh what can I do you for I'm like
well you know I'm watching Engelbert
Humperdinck giving this broad too much
information but uh you know I like the
sound of it I want to order the CD and
he goes great yeah great can I get a
phone number I'm like no you can't not
giving you my phone number he goes well
then I can't complete this order just
like that like I was the 90th person in
a row that said I'm not giving you my
phone number right and he was tired of
hearing it just what he gave me the old
right there Fred well oh I can't do the
order so anything else I can help you
with and I'm like well wait Rob let's go
on we just went from zero to 200 here
why do I have to give you my phone
number
he's like ah you have his phone number
so we can complete the order it's like I
understand you're saying that but I'm
asking you why and he goes all this
because it's company policy and I'm like
why is it company policy if he goes
because I need the phone number in order
to complete the order I go okay see what
we just did there we just drove in a
circle okay I'm trying to get out of the
centrifugal [ __ ] force here and get
over to the reason the [ __ ] reason
right
and he finally just goes well you know
the reason is that if it's a problem
with your order we need to call you and
it's just like well if there's a problem
with the order meaning you charge in my
card and the CDs don't ever come you
know think I'm not going to call you you
get literally had when I called up if
there's a problem with your order press
2 so it just we just keep going round
around go you just want the phone number
and I go not you personally but
time-life does so they can sell it to
other people next thing you know I'm
walking my dog and some countries
calling me up going to congratulations
you're the lucky business winner of
whatever right so it [ __ ] escalates
to a really hostile you have a good
night sir I'm like you're energized next
to the rod right hang up I'm sitting
there for a second right doing the
whisper yelling [ __ ] [ __ ]
Dinka [ __ ] stupid enough to give you
my stomach right all by myself
like a complete lunatic you know in the
background the [ __ ] commercial still
on muskrat internet [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] right [ __ ] send me the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I bought this before and
I'm gonna give you my phone number
freeze he played what for 25 out of 5
right you get my [ __ ] money I'm gonna
call me up agent this is Rob from
time-life just calling to check to see
if you got those CDs right so anyways I
really want these [ __ ] CDs so I call
back again and for some reason I decided
to just go into a southern accent and I
was like when they asked me for their
phone number I'm just for my phone
number I'm just going to give them their
phone number see if they they notice
like can I get your phone number sure
what 800 right I was going to do that
[ __ ] but uh what happened was by the
time the lady picked up there it was the
end of the infomercial it went on to
something else
you know something that neither makes
you skinny or [ __ ] helps clean up
after you goddamn kids I forget what it
was right so she answers the phone she's
like hey this model blah blah blah some
[ __ ] time I'm like I know and I like
to order Liam
AG lessman CDs five easy payments 2995
she's like okay okay get a name of my
ticket to unlock bill Bill burr right so
he does not sound like a southern name
whatever southern bill a joke Bill burr
and actually comes can I get a phone
number I just decided I was just going
to give her area coats I was like my
phone number is eight one eight three
two three two one two five and she goes
okay that number is a one eight three
two three two one two five on my gift
sleeves yes ma'am
it's like I got my take they're going to
[ __ ] show up right my CDs no [ __ ]
problem I gave them a fake email like I
said too damn tall at aol.com
I know what that means can I get an
email art it's to the number two number
two and D a.m. and tall look I didn't
say damn like I was trying to be polite
so then she had to read it back so that
email is number two daamn tall at
aol.com like that's right yes it is and
I got him comic five [ __ ] CDs five
CDs for 30 bucks three payments I don't
know what the [ __ ] it was so it's gonna
be a lot of CDs you know it's funny my
Prius still has a CD holder when my new
car gets here at well and then what the
[ __ ] do I do well I know and I do I sell
them for one easy payment of 995 on eBay
you know and no phone numbers required
just give me a [ __ ] address and I'll
send it to you what do you think about
that
alright come on bill typing you [ __ ]
pass without Jesus question so rumor has
that the Kevin Durant is going to go to
the [ __ ] Golden State Warriors and as
a sports fan I cannot think of a more
boring [ __ ] move
you know what I mean and I [ __ ] hate
how ESPN and all these sports places
they
just don't call them out on it like how
bad that is for sports fans I wanted to
see if Oklahoma see now he hasn't done
it yet but you know sources say rumors
and all that [ __ ] I want to see if you
know what the [ __ ] can Oklahoma City get
by Golden State next year can Golden
State redeem themselves and win a
[ __ ] championship you know it was
such a great series exciting series
Oklahoma had a beat they had that foot
on their neck and then [ __ ] Golden
State comes roaring back this is like
this is great I want to see this again
next year like when the 76ers try to get
past the Celtics dr. J didn't just sign
with the Celtics
grannie they got Moses Malone I guess
it's been going on for a while
I just don't [ __ ] get it don't
[ __ ] get it it's like alright this is
a great rivalry they're evenly matched
it went seven games
hey let's take the best player or one of
the best player ten aren't you like
Westbrook player and we'll just stick
them on the other [ __ ] team and now
that library is null and void now it
goes from Wow
seven game great series to [ __ ] you
know four or five game series who gives
a [ __ ] yeah actually I don't [ __ ] get
it
it's [ __ ] Jerry West going you know
if you sign here your your rebounding is
going to be møtes' more your bloomer
blows can be a cherry you don't give a
[ __ ] you know give a [ __ ] it's all the
best players in the league are all on
one [ __ ] team it's the worst [ __ ]
thing ever you know this is coming from
a Celtics fan and I watched us do that
with that Kevin Kevin Durant team Kevin
Durant Kevin Garnett team you know I
think we just bought this we went from
literally last place to winning the
championship in one [ __ ] year and I
realized that there's a skill to it but
as a crabby old [ __ ] curmudgeon I
just don't like us what is exciting
about that if he go if he signs with the
Golden State Warriors oh that's great
why do you have LeBron jump on that one
to remember those great Miami Heat teams
remember how exciting that was
if you lived in Miami everybody else it
was a [ __ ] snooze fest they'll sit on
a [ __ ] yacht hey y'all want to be on
the same team win three in a row and
we'll be like we'll be a dynasty like
the [ __ ] the Bulls would be like them
yeah except they didn't pile on oh I'm
in a mood I hope that move doesn't
happen you know what's going to happen I
just you know whatever it's his [ __ ]
career but just saying as a sports fan
as a guy who [ __ ] watches sports but
doesn't really pick up on anything and
then runs his [ __ ] mouth on a podcast
I am not in favor of that [ __ ] move
that would suck you know yeah I just
what are you gonna do what think that's
what these kids doing out this I'm
actually it's been going on for 30
[ __ ] years biggest I guess free agent
signing a trade or whatever of my life
of my life was uh Wayne Gretzky going to
the Kings if ever there was an unmovable
guy like there's no [ __ ] way this
franchise has ever getting rid of his
player unless we just completely I don't
know went out of business
folded and had to move or if I don't
know our owner's son [ __ ] finance the
Michael Jackson Victory Tour you know so
now daddy has to sign sell the [ __ ]
team because Michael Jackson stage was
so big and ate up all these [ __ ]
seats that they were losing money every
night and then racist Massachusetts said
that they couldn't do the show out in
Foxborough you know because they didn't
want a bunch of black people coming out
to Foxborough mass going hey for [ __ ]
three hours evidently that was going to
be a problem I could see then making the
[ __ ] move
alright you know that promoter told me
that that's how I always used to think
that one Billy Sullivan the original
owner of the Patriots his son Patrick
somehow was the promoter for the Michael
Jackson victory tour and I remember at
the last second you know it was supposed
to be
Sullivan Stadium which is with the
Patriots old Stadium and at the last
second Foxborough is just like yeah no
you're not having that concert out here
it was just because it was going to be
much black people out there right and
but Michael Jackson had in his contract
that you know once you sign it whether
the show happens and not you got to pay
me I used to think that that one show
[ __ ] him over but this promoter in
Boston told me no he had this giant ass
[ __ ] stage and the Sullivans didn't
take into account this is all alleged
here of the amount of seats that that
was going to take up in the arena you
know and and they didn't realize that
when they will make him a deal they were
calculating a certain number of seats
versus what they were playing the
Jacksons and it all worked out and then
when they saw the behemoth of a [ __ ]
stage they were like oh my god
so they go to Michael they're like
Michael he was like yeah they were like
can you make you stage a little smaller
we're going to lose our shirts here and
Michael Jackson was like no if I had but
smaller prints is going to outdo me like
he had like you know that rivalry with
him going on I don't know if that's
[ __ ] true somebody told me the story
and then I just repeated it it's fact I
mean this this is what I do on the
podcast I'm just running my up here did
anybody watch you watch the Austrian
Grand Prix if that didn't make you a
[ __ ] Formula One racing fan holy [ __ ]
that was like [ __ ] days of fun
actually tweeted that yesterday dude
it's like okay this is the deal the
German team the mercedes-benz right they
got Nico Rosberg and Lewis Hamilton
all right Nico Rosberg is it German
right Lewis Hamilton is uh he's from
England right and evidently from the
Isle of Man from what people were
texting tweeting me the other day
so Nico is ahead he's beating everybody
in the points in the standings and Lewis
is like the [ __ ] an upstart guy I guess
I don't know right he waits the big
[ __ ] diamond chain
you know what I mean he's from East from
England I don't know what his races I
don't know if he's mixed I don't know
what his deal is and he's got the bling
going on and all this [ __ ] so all the
old [ __ ] traditional fans of the
sport traditional wink wink
I like the old-school Formula one wink
wink right you know what that [ __ ]
means they don't like this guy
evidently they don't like his bling they
don't like his you know his whole
bicycle I don't know I don't want to
[ __ ] throw the ugliness in there but
it seems like this little issue there
right so anyways earlier this year I
guess in the Spanish Grand Prix I didn't
see that one
they both [ __ ] they banged into each
other Nico was coming around the corner
he's pushing buttons on that PlayStation
steering wheel whatever the [ __ ] that
thing is you just have a [ __ ] steer
wheel then it was a steering wheel with
the paddles now it looks like a little
Gameboy and they're pushing [ __ ] -
[ __ ] conserve energy and I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is but they somehow do
this going like 180 miles an hour which
is amazing to me 120 miles an hour in a
[ __ ] turn as if they're dealing with
the g-forces of slowing down and taking
a turn well over 100 miles an hour this
sitting on a [ __ ] pushing buttons you
know like texting while driving [ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] so earlier in the year
they had one you know Hamilton tried to
pass him on the inside and then Nico was
defending his position or whatever the
[ __ ] he said he came over he put Lewis
on the [ __ ] grass he spun out he
clipped the back of Nico's car they
slammed into each other and they both
got the oval right there for at the dnc
right did not complete the race which
cost Mercedes a bunch of [ __ ] points
so evidently they probably sat him down
I was like hey [ __ ] heads you're on the
same team here let's say you don't knock
each other out of the race
so whatever they got this whole rivalry
going and it seems like Nico thinks he's
the [ __ ] guy and Louis is this like
well I know you know I respect that
you're the guy but I'm trying to be the
guy - so go [ __ ] yourself so yesterday
they're [ __ ] racing and you know I
don't know much about this sport
but evidently his soft tires and if the
soft tires aren't soft enough they got
super soft tires and I guess the softer
your tires are depending on the weather
condition the faster your car goes so
whatever [ __ ] reason they give Nico
the super soft ones and they give Luis
just the soft ones so they're [ __ ]
them over with each lap all right so
Nico's obviously the golden child that
the corporate guys like and Luis is the
[ __ ] upstart right he's the Tom
Cruise okay the other guys to [ __ ]
establish cont who's winning right I'm
just guessing all of this [ __ ]
so I don't know something about the
pitstop louis's was slower than Nico's
they gave all the [ __ ] advantage to
Nico his Nico's winning in the points I
think that they want him to win the
[ __ ] race because they want to win
the championship and Luis wasn't [ __ ]
having it so he's driving like a [ __ ]
maniac on soft tires when Nico's got the
super soft and next thing you know he's
right on his [ __ ] ass it's the last
lap of the [ __ ] race and Luis goes to
pass him on the outside of the turn
taking the long way around he's on his
[ __ ] tire on the white line he can't
get over any farther if he's going to
pass if you see he's going to overtake
him on the final lap the [ __ ]
announces to going nuts and [ __ ] Nico
just drove right into him he said he had
a braking problem it's like oh yeah did
you have a steering problem - you
[ __ ] drove right into him and it's
like oh my god they're going to knock
each other out of the race again and
they get out of it and then they came
back together and [ __ ] I think the
back of Hamilton's car clipped the front
of Rosberg's and took a little fin fin
things off the front so now we can't
drive fast and when you cars damaged
like that you blow and debris all over
the track I didn't realize this
evidently you're supposed to pull over
supposed to hit the old rest area and
just be like well I guess we're going to
call it a day because all that [ __ ] that
you're putting in the track can blow out
somebody's tire caused him to crash they
could get injured and they're not going
to [ __ ] finish and it's not their
fault that you [ __ ] drove into your
teammate but this [ __ ] in his car
shrapnel all over the track and he
finished he got penalized launch story
short was Lewis Hamilton and of when
in the [ __ ] race and they were cut
into the whatever the owners of the
Mercedes team and they're all [ __ ]
pissed
and one of the guys on the Mercedes
teams is the guy that you know and for
that movie rush should really have the
guy's name here I'm new to the sport so
forgive me for not knowing his name the
guy who had that horrific crash on the
Ferrari team in 1976 we had the fire
they showed it in that movie rush it was
absolutely terrifying and what's more
terrifying than being alive on fire you
know I mean what would you rather be
alive on fire or in the ocean watching a
great white shark approaching you know
knowing it's going to [ __ ] take your
leg off I mean I actually think you got
to go with the shark
just [ __ ] bite my leg off there's a
major artery right there I'm going to
[ __ ] and be like ah and then the
dopamine is going to come out and that
goofy smile on my face is the hammerhead
comes in to finish me off
right so anyways they would talk to him
afterwards Nico said that he had a
break-in problem I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know so now there's all these
conspiracy theorists out there going
like well you know it's the German team
Nico's a German all right [ __ ]
Hamilton's uh you know from England and
he doesn't look like your [ __ ]
English guy being meaning he's not a
white dude maybe there's some racism
going on there I don't know but I just
became a Lewis Hamilton I feel like
Rosberg gay time he's racing he's out
that you know can't [ __ ] handle it
he's one of those he seems like one of
those guys you ever go out you play like
pick-up hoop a pick-up hockey and it's
just some [ __ ] nice guy and all of a
sudden the game starts and they get that
[ __ ] look in their face like they'll
blow out a knee just to score a goal you
know those lunatics you just sitting
there going like alright I'm gonna
[ __ ] steer clear slash try to annoy
the [ __ ] out of this person I'm gonna
try to make sure this guy doesn't fall
on my [ __ ] leg you know I had a buddy
of mine write [ __ ] nicest guy ever
psychiatrist he works with troubled
inner-city youth who just gone through
all kinds of [ __ ] horrific [ __ ] he
has the patience to sit there you know
and work with these kids that are acting
out because of all this horrible stuff
that that's happened to in their home
life and he sits there and he handles it
he loves it he'd [ __ ] get that guy
out on the ice he's a [ __ ] lunatic
one time I took the mean the other guy
we [ __ ] taking the puck away from him
and he I heard his breathing change and
he just [ __ ] brought his stick up and
I'm telling you this is why I wear the
full bird cage right dude 45-degree
angle across my whole face it just BAM
it hit my [ __ ] cage and I looked at I
was just like dude what the [ __ ]
whatever dumb reason I was one of those
people you know that comes out plays
pick-up hockey only wearing a visor
those guys are lunatics especially women
because it's always the person out there
that can't skate which is usually me and
you start doing that run in place I'm
going to fall forward I'm going to fall
back I'm going to fall forward you got
like this stick in your hand that's
coming up and taking somebody's teeth
out so oh my god what a literally would
have needed like [ __ ] plastic surgery
that was kid new [ __ ] face like mine
you just ride it out oh there's his name
right there I got it right here I'm
sorry Nicky I'm gonna say wrong la UDA I
don't know I say la de I sorta so he was
they talked to him and I'm looking at
this guy looking like the old racing guy
like one of his ears is like you know
mostly burned off and [ __ ] he's got the
scars on the side of his face I got to
be honest with you he looked pretty
[ __ ] badass you don't to me and
another guy named I swear to God toto
wolff total like the band I went up
that's on the CD I wanna do an awake at
the in the moaning is he alright let's
do a couple of reads here well Jesus I
was thirty two [ __ ] minutes it just
run in my yep Oh simple space we have
somebody know here everybody simple safe
thousands of people seeking home
security get ripped off every day at the
home security industry and and
home security industry wants you to
believe it's your only option
they got hordes of salesmen out there
trying to scare you into signing one of
their long term contracts you get stuck
writing huge checks month after month
with capital letters no way out it's
robbery by contract and it can cost you
thousands but there's a better way to
protect your home simple safe home
security what the [ __ ] are they talking
about these contracts at home security
is you want you to believe it's your
only option what do they do they sign
you to a contract to do what simple
faith has no contracts none you get
award-winning 24/7 protection named best
in the industry
all I see security professionals
watching ready to instantly send the
police and it's just that they're not
going to go in and do something jesus
[ __ ] christ I could do that there's
got to be another Rihanna I know they
sit in the van alright my fault sorry
simple state I just simple safe I
thought they wouldn't tell you have a
home safe
it's just $14.99 per month that's less
than half of what most companies charge
protect your home the smart way visit
simple safe just a simple place safe
birth I'm suing that / / I know so
simple safe birbee you are are calm
today for an exclusive 10% offer
it's got to be slash bar has to be and
get a free key chain remote worth 25
bucks only when you go to simple safe
bird calm that's simple safe bird calm
nope that's right no that might be
wanted done alright blue apron everybody
ah blue apron blue apron knows that when
you cook with incredible ingredients you
make incredible meals so they set the
highest quality standards for their
community of artisanal supplies
suppliers family-run farms fisheries and
ranches whether it's Japanese ramen
noodles wild-caught Alaskan salmon or
heirloom tomatoes blue apron is bringing
you
the best none of that [ __ ] existed when
I was a kid it's all because of the food
network like the level of options you
now have as a person to eat you know
what I mean it was [ __ ] chipped beef
on toast chicken noodle soup tuna
casserole right cube steaks these
[ __ ] kids today this is what they can
eat these four kids in that 20
struggling they can actually have some
great blue apron it you go from that
horseshit to Japanese ramen noodles wild
caught Alaskan salmon heirloom tomatoes
there was one molested ten bucks per
meal blue apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with pre-portioned
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals variety new recipes
are created each week by blue aprons
culinary team and are not repeated
within a year
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences choose delivery
options to fit your needs
there's no weekly commitment so you only
get deliveries when you want them so if
you got a lady in your life you can cook
her some meals if she [ __ ] Lygia you
can go right back to [ __ ] eatin what
the [ __ ] that we used to have Statham oh
I love the steak I swear to God the last
nine periods of my school day I would be
sitting there thinking about the steak
him I was going to make when I got home
right fry it up in the pan like some one
of those [ __ ] with the high heels in
the lipstick right and then you put it
on the white bread and watch the grease
turning gray a little bit of ketchup and
some cheese [ __ ] phenomenal but
anyways back to blue apron each meal
comes with step-by-step easy-to-follow
recipe cards and pre-portion ingredients
and can be prepared in 40 minutes or
less
check out this week's menu and get you
two meals for free with free shipping by
blue apron by going to blue apron com /
/ you will love how good it feels and
tasty create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait
that's blue apron calm / / blue apron a
better way to cook we got left here we
got two more left let's break it up okay
let's let's give you a break from my
reading out loud or my attempt that we
will go back to the [ __ ] clock
where did I go where did I go where the
[ __ ] is the other [ __ ] but uh did any D
alright so should we get into the reeds
here for this week
why don't we alright governor Gary
Jackson Gary Johnson sorry governor Gary
Johnson hey Billy Shatner Billy [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm not a libertarian I never said
you were
I'd never been affiliated with any party
I voted both parties in for elections I
voted in
I've been eligible for six you sound
like a blogger when you're going to
criticize a comedian going like I have a
great sense of humor you know I find
this funny I love this and blah blah
blah but what I saw last night in the
comedy club all right so this guy's
established himself that he's
open-minded all right because he says so
I'm not into the fringe candidates and I
don't buy into conspiracies I guess what
I'm saying is I'm not the typical Gary
Johnson fan now what could you say so I
guess what I'm saying is well why don't
you figure out what the [ __ ] you saying
so you don't have to write extra words
in a sentence giving me more opportunity
to trip myself up please all right
however I am a fan of his and I think he
could actually win if he got on on the
debate he's basically Bernie who I
supported for the most part they I'm not
a libertarian well he was a Democrat
right now well he was and then he became
libertarian then became a Democrat is
that how it worked I don't know I love
Bernie Sanders oh love they aligned on
80% of the issues his running mate is
former Massachusetts governor bill well
bill weld still in the game like [ __ ]
Gordie Howe rested piece wondering what
your thoughts on Gary Johnson and also
bill weld having lived in the state when
he was in office below is a short
campaign video of the two of them well I
want what the [ __ ] I don't know I
thought you were going to tell me about
it I guess I was supposed to watch
just before you dude you just gave me
homework alright let's put this [ __ ]
thing in here and we're going to try and
watch it oh [ __ ] I've brought in some
pears in it I'm ready I'll bill well I'm
running with it
jazzy music as the governor of New
Mexico I hate old wasteful spending 750
times cut taxes 14 times unless it's
well why do so breathy how would I know
that you just said that you did it now
how do i I can't fact check all of that
I don't know I mean it's exciting we're
going to move the country forward music
but a little delay hi I'm Jerry Johnson
I'm sure he's a great guy I'll look into
it I mean I liked you're giving me other
options because there's no [ __ ] way I
can vote for Trump or for Hillary you
know oh we all know the old bags gonna
win it she's going to show up and
lipstick on her teeth and that [ __ ]
maniacal wide-eyed [ __ ] smile she
does oh she's going to carve this
country up even more they are [ __ ]
evil I swear to God if Trump wasn't such
a [ __ ] dope if he wasn't such a dope
I actually think he would be the lesser
of two evils but I have to be honest
with you there's no way to listen to
Donald Trump and not think about Martin
Sheen in the dead zone did somebody
please Photoshop Trump holding up the
baby you know and [ __ ]
what's-his-face
oh Jesus Christ when walking's up in the
balcony there or the dead [ __ ] knob
the birds are away gentlemen I have no
idea sir I commend you for being smart
enough to not vote for Trump or for
Hillary it's a
it's a really low point and I wasn't a
big Obama fan but at least Obama at
least you know the guy could speak
intelligently you know after [ __ ]
eight years of George Bush and that guy
was that guy was like the presidential
version of me reading out loud all right
there has to be so many other [ __ ]
women out there that would me make such
great honest presidents we really have
why does it have to be the one with 52
pending felony counts all those Clintons
are filthy Oh Hillary Clinton she's
dirtier than our husbands dick all right
here we go facial hair and low lady
alright what's going on I forgot to do
two weeks I'm actually in my garage
right now that's all
alright score big score big Mickey on
doll again really an apple amazing in
here right score fit you're paying too
much for tickets between all the mock
ups and last-minute convenience judges
even prison homepage what are you
[ __ ] kidding me do you end up paying
courtside prices for nosebleed seats
score big is here to change that did you
know that 40% of all live event tickets
go unsold and did you know that there's
a place to get these feeds a huge
savings it's called score big score big
works directly with your favorite teams
and Attis to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices only with score big
can you name a ticket price and be
guaranteed to paid below box office up
to 60% off here's what you do one go to
score big calm and download the new
score big app on your iPhone and find
the event and seats you want to make an
offer with score big name a ticket price
feature 3 get an instant answer and save
up to 60% on your tickets never in fees
and shipping is always free you can
count on unbeatable prices and great
seats when you're in and when you're in
great seats you actually draw the game
or the show all the more next time see
any game or show go to score big first
and see how much you can save so the
easiest way to save on tickets download
the scope
app on your iPhone you're going to fold
it this [ __ ] and a promo code Burt at
the checkout and you'll save an extra 20
bucks off your first ticket purchase
nope no iPhone no problem get $20 up
online at score big gun that score big
compro micawber for VidCon promo code
Burke okay all the cool it is but I'll
still do bianchi me undies where AM in a
[ __ ] garage Biondi me undies get a
small not a lodge headin snug and tight
up on the ball no more sweaty nuts and
that cat all they come in cool colors
you'll a deal like them maybe she'll
suck your dick oh yeah and do it on the
4th of July
how many mean it aren't money whether
you're wearing a suit or sweat you spend
almost 24 hours a day in your underwear
unless you're a [ __ ] animal but
instead of making a statement like
Superman spike unders everyday clothes
your underwear is probably boring the
undies is here to change that please
include all the fallen mobile motels
every pair of the undies is made from a
sustainable source model of fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton nothing
to describe the fit and feel of the
undies but once you try them on you'll
understand why they are called the
world's most comfortable underwear
and if you don't love the first pair of
the undies they're free no questions
that eonni says dozens of styles and
limited edition prints to help you make
a statement with your underwear whether
anyone can see him or not remember
Superman
alright shipping it's free in the US in
Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair
with the me undies subscription plan get
the subscription or a single pair get
20% off your first order when you go to
the undies dog calm / fur but young
news.com slash fur for 20% off Yanni's
dot-com slash birth dear big Billy yes
fat Billy I'm a 17 year old guy who will
be starting college in the fall in the
great state of Massachusetts
Jesus starting at 7 you must be turning
18 later on the year
I'm boys jealous of that I started I
started college when I was 19 I was
already 19 then I [ __ ] up my first 4
years and I was like a 23 year old
sophomore my high school dress code
allows guys to grow facial hair and the
last semester of senior year what what
foots [ __ ] school you going to so a
few months ago I said what the hell I'll
give it a try but you're only 17 the
last semester of your senior year you're
getting giving yourself a hell of a lot
of time to grow this [ __ ] said I end up
growing up growing a nice dark full
beard that seems to suit me well I got a
lot of compliments for it mostly from
other guys but some from the ladies I
remain single as I have always been
during this time I still have the beard
now
but I don't know whether I should keep
the beard or ditch it and arrive at
college clean shaven
do you think it's a good or bad idea to
make my first impression while sporting
a beer in terms of the ladies is the
beard a sign of manliness and strength
or more of a turn-off I don't [ __ ] I
gotta ask me a hang on a second Jesus
Christ how the [ __ ] would I know you
know I always thought Dan Fox was sexy
hang on
are you happy she was sleeping I just I
didn't know she was sleeping on [ __ ]
nightmare yeah man all right well there
you go
say it [ __ ] the whole thing I've cleaned
up and then I woke her up and I do it I
don't [ __ ] know what you're saying it
you're not you're not allowed to grab
facial hairs with this [ __ ] school
you go was that like a type typo or
something my oh my high school's not
College my high schools dress code
allows guys to grow facial hair in the
last semester of senior year oh okay I
thought of Shane at college um well look
do when I was a kid the only reason to
grow a beard was so you could buy booze
or get served when you were still
underage you know whether women like it
or not I have no [ __ ] idea I don't I
don't know go there [ __ ] clean-shaven
and then you know get a little scruff
going or some [ __ ] I don't know this is
like a Cosmo question I have no [ __ ]
today is it a sign of manliness I have
no idea I mean if you grow it too
quickly it might be a sign of a hairy
back and that might take you out of the
game some women might be like oh my dad
had a beard in the subconsciously that
gets into them you know oh yeah that
reminds me of feeling safe with my dad
and next thing you know they're blowing
yeah then they're like what the [ __ ] did
what happened right I don't know let's
move on in the next quit that was a hard
one I had no [ __ ] idea all right
cheating [ __ ] girlfriend oh Jesus hey
you red face [ __ ] I don't know why I
find that [ __ ] so endearing showed you
what the [ __ ] wrong with me all right
about a month ago I started dating this
lady she seemed really quiet and pretty
innocent after about a week I realized I
just pictured that woman in that Vince
Vaughn movie the wedding crashes whoever
that actress was is [ __ ] hilarious in
that movie anyways after about a week I
realized that her last boyfriend was a
total freak like Jean
shorts and [ __ ] [ __ ] we mean freak like
a weirdo what was [ __ ] you know having
threesomes with this chick anyways like
jean shorts and [ __ ] [ __ ] so I did my
best to just ignore that and have fun
together I was in my opinion a great
boyfriend to her I took her on a lot of
dates and it seemed like everything was
perfect and this was my first girlfriend
I'm only 16 and pretty introverted so
having a girlfriend was a big step for
me yeah that's huge good for you man
anyways after a few weeks she started
acting weird one day at lunch she told
me that her old weird boyfriend and her
had sex before school that day and they
also had sex a couple other times while
we were going out I didn't know what to
say that really [ __ ] me up she even
said it wasn't her fault and I shouldn't
be mad oh you know what I was actually
going to give this girl props to be
mature enough to own up to what the [ __ ]
she did and then she said that don't be
mad at me after a fight I told her to
[ __ ] I told her to [ __ ] and left
I think [ __ ] off that's what you meant
she's already [ __ ] dude you don't
need to tell her you should have told
her the less [ __ ] 2x nay on the [ __ ] a
she then started saying that it was my
fault I don't know what I did wrong
oh you pulled Basten you're only 16
years old right so you didn't have your
deflector shields up is that what it is
did you say you were 16 right the [ __ ]
was that I'm only 16 okay so now
everyone knows at school because high
school is [ __ ] I know I am now known
by everyone including my family as the
guy who got cheated on this [ __ ] not
only made me feel like [ __ ] but also
kind of ruined the whole aspect of
finding a nice girl I don't trust them
and feel as if I will never move on yeah
these are the catastrophic thoughts you
have when you're 60 because your world
is small you're still living at home
with your parents you go to school you
see the same [ __ ] [ __ ] every day and
you feel like the walls are closing in
all of these feelings 100% norm
how do you how do you move on after
being [ __ ] over like that
the only things I've done is got a job
and started lifting weights maybe then
when school starts again I can show up
shredded and do better next year there
you go I like it turn a negative into a
positive
here's the thing you're a nice guy right
you're a nice guy well you know so that
means there's the nice woman out there
that balances you out right if your
addictive plenty of concept there but
you're a nice guy so what I would do is
I would thank my lucky stars that that
[ __ ] woman is out of your life you
know she's totally [ __ ] up right she's
going to go back to the gene short guy
and they're going to [ __ ] before school
and they're going to do all of this
other [ __ ] and who gives a [ __ ] I don't
understand how like I don't know how
there's no reason for you just me
listening to this why you should feel
bad about yourself oh yeah you know I
got cheated on you know it's happened to
everybody and it makes you just more
feel stupid is what it is you know what
I mean
so trying to count the amount of times
that's happening to me the first girl I
was with was like [ __ ] way older than
me I went from like zero to ninety miles
an hour and [ __ ] yeah she ended up
cheating on me and breaking up a [ __ ]
marriage and I didn't I I didn't even
know I ended up running into the life of
the guy that she cheated with and then
they were broken up and she told me and
I just minded my my thought was I just
felt like huh you know and it was a lot
in that because it just let me know
that you know I just thought guys did
[ __ ] like that
you know I thought we would just the
[ __ ] animals it was just like wow she
was doing that and then come home and
smile yeah and that [ __ ] me up for a
long [ __ ] time yeah you know what and
I didn't trust women you know and I
started lifting weights did I write this
thing 20 years ago what the [ __ ] no yeah
this is the deal you know it's going to
take time to get over it but you know
you're going to meet somebody nice and I
think yet you're the prime of your life
to throw the weights around a little bit
you show up [ __ ] shredded right and
then you show you I show up in September
and just start chatting up the women and
this is a thing two women love a [ __ ]
they love a project you know so you can
use the fact that this woman cheated on
you that oh you know I have problems
trusts and [ __ ] women and now they'll
just know they'll be coming at you you
beat them off with a [ __ ] stick all
right yeah [ __ ] that this is the thing
you don't ever let it any time anything
bad happens in life you don't have what
you don't let it you know there's two
things you can do you can either just
[ __ ] I don't I I do like those those
types of thoughts like you know when you
watch like Bugs Bunny and they have like
that weight that just said one ton on it
I've you like that that's what that
thought is alright and you stand-in next
to a [ __ ] pool alright and the things
got a chain around it and you either
just [ __ ] let it go to the bottom of
the pool itself or you stick your head
in the chain and wrap it around your
neck and you let it take you down and
then you just down there in the bottom
of the pool you know why would you do
that [ __ ] it [ __ ] you [ __ ] just let
that totally I'm not saying don't deal
with it but you got to turn it into a
positive which is what you seem to be
doing [ __ ] workout and chat up a
bunch of women is to think maybe yeah
you know start your list of [ __ ]
requirements you test you lock the door
test and maybe to try to get a good one
you know women always say find a good
finding a good a good man's hard to find
sews a good woman so what this woman did
is help you start early on a checklist
because I didn't start a checklist for a
long [ __ ] time
you know I was well into my 30s and I
was still just like hey you want to [ __ ]
every saw everything ah you do
everything on my list is checked off you
know all right here we go all time
underrated quarterback you'll be fine
you'll be fine
shake it off [ __ ] your fault that
select for a woman she's got a lot of
issues and I bet she has a terrible
father you know so in a way you can look
at it like that because you know she is
young and immature but if she continues
to live her life that way that is that
is a bad [ __ ] road to go on you know
that's [ __ ] white Simpson Dale's are
the red wine gray teeth with the [ __ ]
[ __ ] stamp she's going to go down that
one yeah and the piece of [ __ ] guys
she's going to meet jean shorts will be
the least of her problems I hope that
doesn't happen there either but anyways
here we go all time underrated cubies
dear Billy white shoes
very nice reference Billy white shoes
Johnson of the Houston Oilers and the
Lana Falcon all right my friends care me
apart for being a huge Vinny Testaverde
fan I truly love the man and feel he
flies under the radar as an all-time
quarterback maybe not Hall of Fame
caliber but someone who could have won a
Super Bowl if he didn't have to face
Elway Terrell Davis in the 1998 Denver
Bronco machine well you really what you
say that he could have been a
championship if he didn't have to play
the best team in the league well I mean
yeah well [ __ ] San Diego Padres could be
a [ __ ] dynasty if it wasn't for all
the other three the [ __ ] in 1998 Yankees
you know or the late 90s Yankees right
no anyways he played 22 seasons and in
his final season with season with the
Carolina Panthers he won his first game
after only being on the team for three
[ __ ] days at the age of 43 he was
definitely a badass nobody could be in
that backyard playing horseshoes with
his son and then out of football in two
days later be honest under center and
[ __ ] winning a game like he did that
like I think three times in his career
he was sort of like a maybe it just
happened one side
no but I just feel like he was
officially retired at least once if not
twice and he was in the backyard eat the
[ __ ] burger having a Coors Light and
all of a sudden hey Benny
this is the [ __ ] whatever Seattle
Seahawks Colin no Tampa but what did he
play Tampa the Jets Carolina that's a
great one
Cleveland did he play with Cleveland it
was at Bernie Koza
again I get confused my older age let's
look up old Vinny Testaverde vete then
he had the [ __ ] deal all right you
guys want to hear a great you guys wanna
hear a great [ __ ] LA story I went out
to an Italian restaurant the other day
right and was sitting up front near the
bar and was too loud and one of the guys
I was eating was because it's too
[ __ ] loud let's try to get a table in
the back so they end up hooking us up
with the table in the back and as I'm
going to walk you know to the back one
of the guys there up the bar he goes
yeah go in the back you know you can
barely hear yourself thinking just the
way he said it I can't remember what he
said he said something along those lines
super Italian guy and the way he said it
and the fact that I was moving as I went
past him I felt like I was in that
tracking scene in Goodfellas when they
were showing all those characters you
know get the papers get the papers hey
guy a guy took care of that thing right
that literally it gave me like a shock
the way he said it
so I said to one of the guys I was
having dinner with I said hey my goat
cheese clients go that guy just made me
feel like I was in Goodfellas classic la
story and why it's so amazing to live
out here EKOS do you know who that is
and I said no he goes that's the guy who
played Johnny roast beef and then I
[ __ ] looked at him again I was like
oh my god this Johnny roast beef one of
the greatest pieces [ __ ] acting I've
ever seen is when he's trying to explain
away that pink Cadillac and he starts to
stop and then then he starts to talk and
then he stops and actually had I talked
to him about it for a second and he just
laughed he said one that basically said
when a man if scary is Jimmy the gent is
yelling at ya he goes you don't say a
[ __ ] word
no it's in my grandmother's name what's
the matter with me what's the matter of
me you're going to get us all [ __ ]
pinched that's why the matter with you
no matter with you take it back take it
back it the [ __ ] that look on his
[ __ ] face and he goes just keep going
I'm sorry I'm sorry what did I tell you
what is [ __ ] what did I [ __ ] love
that seat
so anyways Vinny Testaverde here we go
Benny [ __ ] Testaverde over here we go
Vinny Testaverde let's see him with the
Panthers he's 52 years old I swear to
God I bet he's still in shape and if you
[ __ ] if you you know if you call him
up right now you call him up right now
he can give you a decent honor what the
[ __ ]
87 to 92 we played for the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers 93 to 95 he played for the
Cleveland Browns 96 97 the Baltimore
Ravens 98 to 2003 the New York Jets
which is how I remember him as a jet
2004 the Dallas Cowboys 2005 he goes
back to the Jets 2006 he played for my
Patriots I don't even remember that 2007
he played for the Panthers 20 year
[ __ ] career 21 seasons Wow
two-time Pro Bowler 96 98 Heisman Trophy
86 davey o'brien buh-buh-buh-buh Sammy
Baugh trophy sportsman of the year 86
let's see T DS verse interceptions this
is what [ __ ] them over though 275
touchdowns 267 interceptions wasn't
somebody wrapped like that incomplete
like Testaverde but you didn't say
intercepted but he threw for 46,000 233
yards back in the day you know for the
most part when you actually they could
cover receivers before Jim Irsay changed
all the
[ __ ] rules because he couldn't beat
the Patriots but that's okay I know the
ball was under inflated let's kick him
out of football passing rating passing
passer rating seventy five point oh
alright well yeah okay those a great
[ __ ] you know do you play twenty seasons
he did throw a lot of pics so anyways
where he's the oldest quarterback to
ever start and win a pro football game
older than George Blanda
thought George Blaine maybe he was just
kicking at that point everybody always
reversed back to the days his days in
Tampa and Cleveland but I'd argue that
those Tampa years were some of the worst
Pro squads ever to trot on a football
onto a football field yeah absolutely
you can't blame somebody for that you
know it's like Joey Harrington he goes
any [ __ ] place for the Lions you know
ought right out of the gate there's no
way he's bad he's as bad as he looked
those lion teams were [ __ ] horrible
I'm not saying that the guy would have
played in the league or whatever but you
know for the longest time if you got
drafted by the lines or the Browns as a
quarterback that was a [ __ ] death
sentence which is another brilliant move
that John Elway made because when he got
drafted by the Baltimore Colts he's like
I'm not [ __ ] going there getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of me and I'll be out of
football I mean that almost happened to
Troy Aikman Troy Aikman when he got
drafted by the [ __ ] Cowboys so got
the living [ __ ] kicked out of him his
first two years if that continued I mean
that guy he would have been out of
football but fortunately the Herschel
Walker trade went down with Jimmie
Johnson a boys right they got that
[ __ ] uh all those 300 pounders in
front of them I don't know anyways let's
plow ahead here uh he said as a Patriots
fan I'd like your thoughts on him are my
friends right saying he was just an
average quarterback at best no [ __ ]
way
no way no way he was he was well you
don't play for 20 [ __ ] years okay he
was he was above way above average I
think I think he was a he's not I
wouldn't say he's one of the greats but
he was definitely
a he was a really good quarterback you
know he wasn't like um what if he was if
he was an average QB at best you don't
play for 20 years be an average unless
you Steve de Burgh and just somehow you
just look so great with a headset in the
clipboard people just wanted you around
he was like the David Hasselhoff you
know a [ __ ] quarterback it just I
think you sold more tickets because he
never had his helmet on the ladies could
come down and look at him look up Steve
de Berg here Steve de Berg all right
oh yeah the David Hasselhoff he looks
like he looked like you know whenever
they had those coming-of-age movies and
you got the nerd who wants to date the
[ __ ] cheerleader but she's dating the
guy who's just a complete [ __ ] dick
he had those those level good looks dude
I'm telling you right now look this guy
up that's [ __ ] hilarious he looks
like he's on Baywatch played number 17
on now he goes up this is this you know
what this is actually morphed into the
degraded NFL's greatest journeyman I'm
going to look this up great is oh god I
love the Internet I love that somebody's
made a page about this [ __ ] best NFL
journeyman the seven most unkillable
journeyman quarterbacks I love the
internet because of [ __ ] like this and
all the [ __ ] free porn all right here
we go there's a good chance that at one
time or another your team's hopes were
riding on Ryan Fitzpatrick Brian Hoyer
or one of the NFL's other well traveled
signal callers aw don't be all just new
guys come on all right Ryan Fitzpatrick
Ryan Fitzpatrick a played for the Texans
the Titans the Rams the Bengals the Jets
and the bills all right Josh McCown
Brian Hoyer and all Matt Cassel
[ __ ] Matt Flynn the perennial backup
so come on man Tim Tebow ah now this
this was done by some youngster you got
to have Steve the Bergen there you got a
Vinny Testaverde journeymen NFL players
who just won't go away
do I have to type in all time is that
what I have to do I think I got to type
in all time come on man you got it if if
you if Steve the bars not on your
[ __ ] list he's not on your [ __ ]
list journeyman quarterback all right
we'll just go Wikipedia oh this is
depressing I thought it's going to be
great JT O'Sullivan played for 12
professional teams during his career you
know I bet in his mancave he f L should
give him all 12 of those helmets all 12
of those [ __ ] helmets family all
wrapped up in the [ __ ] court you all
right here we go this is what happens
when you [ __ ] lay down on a couch is
why is JT O'Sullivan he played on no
less than 11 NFL teams Oh professionals
okay so and then he also played for the
Saskatoon Rough Riders in the frankfurt
galaxy Chris Chandler holds the record
for starting a game for the highest
number of different NFL teams with eight
also he started okay
there's no accepted definition or
threshold of which a person is regarded
as a journeyman quarterback the term is
descriptive rather than definitive David
Craig enjoyed 11 stable careers with the
Seahawks before leaving that's the mark
Rypien
notable examples here we go here we go
Trent Dilfer
Brad Johnson Rich Gannon where the [ __ ]
is Steve de Burgh notable journeyman
quarterbacks come on come on
you know I'm sure look up Steve de Burgh
I'm sorry guys this whole podcast just
you just listen to me surf the [ __ ]
Internet now people still say surf the
Internet is that from the 90s I'm old
now he's 62 years old he played for the
San Francisco 49ers from 1977 to 1980
the Broncos from 81 to 83
the Buccaneers from 84 to 87 the Chiefs
from 88 to 91 back to the Buccaneers 90
to 93 the Miami Dolphins 1993 he was out
of [ __ ] football in 94 he was out of
football in 95 out of football 96 out of
football 97 and then what the [ __ ] 1998
he's back with the dirty Birds the
Atlanta Falcons who upset the 15 in 1
Minnesota Vikings right and then went to
the [ __ ] Super Bowl one of the most
forgettable Super Bowls of all [ __ ]
time when the Denver Broncos repeated
that was the last [ __ ] game of John
Elway's career alright TDS two
interceptions he had a hundred ninety
six touchdowns versus two hundred four
interceptions he threw for 34,000 241
yards and as a higher QB rating than
Vinny Testaverde at 70 4.2 right was
he's 75 I don't [ __ ] remember Steven
Lee Roy de Berg there you go that's
that's my that's my vote you know it's
funny like I bet he doesn't have a lot
of problems walking or anything like
that because he's got so he has a low
miles on that odometer as far as like
actually playing in the fly my trying to
assault a guy here I'm just saying like
if he was a car you know be like those
are all original miles being yeah yeah
he sent a garage with a [ __ ]
clipboard for all those years all right
that's the podcast for this this 4th of
July hope you guys all have a happy and
a safe one all right you [ __ ] drunks
I know it's a fireworks and supposed to
be fun but you know they are explosives
don't be that person
and what
those YouTube [ __ ] videos of like top
10 stupidest [ __ ] moves done with
fireworks did you see that [ __ ] guy
he actually took like a mortar or some
[ __ ] put it on his head
I don't know if he thought it was going
to take off he literally blew himself up
his friends go you don't understand
there was nothing left of him there was
nothing left to help you no they just
showed up and there was there was like a
belt buckle and like a shoelace he was
gone so please don't do that to yourself
alright alright cRIO
alright that's the podcast you guys have
a great week
I will check in with you go [ __ ]
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday alright